i understand you're a big believer in um
self-manifestation
why is that
be hard to put a finger on it except for
the fact that i've seen it work
i've i've seen things that i've
visualized materialized
and so i'm totally subscribed to it now
i guess because
i've been blessed with so much stuff in
my life that
i feel like you can tailor your life to
your liking
what is your process when it comes to
that do you take time out
of your day to sit and think about what
you want and make it happen or what
you know i would recommend people to do
that it's never been um
something i took conscious time out to
do if it was something that came natural
it was something that um and i mean that
in the most humble way possible i
since i was a young kid i would see
something i wanted and i if i focus on
it i would make it happen
so um it comes natural to me for the
things i want
i go after them how would you describe
the past couple years of your life in a
single word
destiny destiny
that goes back to what we just talked
about
is this all something that you imagined
from a young age i mean people always
say they dream of something
but how far back can you go that you can
imagine this was your destiny
a decade back since i was 11 or 12 this
is what i've been imagining for myself
at what point did you realize this could
actually become a career what was a
turning point
for some reason a decade ago when i was
11 or 12 i felt like this is what i'm
gonna do
i remember i started quietly moving
college
out of the picture in my head and
realizing that
this is what excited me in life and it
it's beyond just rap music it's
expression and writing and so for me at
an early age
that's what made me feel alive and still
makes me feel alive when i make
something that is profound
authentic and fire
you recently posted about going back to
old high school and then running into
one year old teachers
you know like high school brings back a
lot of emotions like going back to the
grounds brings back a lot of emotions
for a lot of people
i imagine when you're someone in high
school dreaming the dreams that you had
and saying what you're going to be
you came up against a lot of people that
were like yeah okay whatever
right did you have was that something
that you ever heard
anything you ever listened to what was
your experience like with that
yeah i heard that and to this day i hear
versions of that you know there's still
skeptics and doubters and people that
don't really see it for me
and it's just fuel you know for me it's
fuel it's what
it's what gives me that energy to feel
confident it's where those cocky records
come from
um is people telling me i can't do
something so i never like to be tethered
to anyone else's opinion or
any limits they set on me so but yeah in
high school i used to hear it all the
time i used to have kids that would
i was well liked in high school and um i
actually won most talented in the
yearbook so it wasn't
complete skepticism but of course there
were haters
of course there were haters is it
something that you hear
um you know those few voices that you
hear louder when you got that
self-doubt or did you ever or was that
even something in your mind you always
believe this is going to be what it is
i always believed it but it's all
fleeting it's all in spurts
and luckily the self-belief came enough
and it's still coming enough but the
self-doubt
still comes around the insecurities
still peak out so it's a mix it's never
going to be all the way up for anyone
there's always going to be moments of
doubt
so um
but yeah the hate is always louder
that's why i try not to ever respond to
it because
there's so much love if it's 90 love and
10
hate and you respond to the hate all
that love is like
damn you ain't going you ain't going to
acknowledge me
it's interesting you like what's poppin
has been getting so much of that love
like millions and millions
of streams right but then like you said
you've got
fleeting moments of what feel like
success and victory did
the success of that kind of weigh on you
for
the next steps for the next things that
you wanted to do
yeah it was the biggest it was the
largest scale version of that because
i've had success prior to that it was
smaller but i would have records that
did okay in my i had a record that did
good in my high school
then a record that did good in my city
suddenly i have a record that's doing
good on facebook
nationwide then i have a record that has
a moment on world star hip hop and
instagram so that
it keeps getting bigger and bigger and
suddenly i make a smash
that's a commercial success so the
pressure's always been there to get
better and not plateau
so that's not new it's just this time
oh we got to take it up a notch we
really got to take it up a notch because
i've been dropped into a new world and a
new
set of expectations and um
now it makes you want to deliver more
i'm hungry
so what does it mean now to you what is
that next notch
that you got to take it up to i think
the the quality control for me has just
been
rising higher and higher songs that used
to be oh that's pretty good i just
um that's not good enough to come out
because you
you raise the standard for yourself so i
have songs from a year ago two years ago
that i was like
hmm i think i would drop this now i
wouldn't drop
it now now songs have to be better to
come out because i just
uh feels like everybody had to get in on
what's pop and justin bieber even got in
on what's poppin
and i know that wasn't like an official
thing but what was your reaction when
you heard it
that was fire i loved i loved and i
loved how it happened it felt organic
you know it kind of leaked
and it was this sort of pop hip-hop
moment it was it was fly
because bieber's cool man like bieber's
iconic
so for him to just touch that even if
it's a 30 second snippet to hear his
voice on that beat
the beat is forever immortalized aside
from what i did on it which
the song is in many ways a classic the
beat
the beat is forever you can play that on
the radio other people are going to rap
on it people know that b
when that beat comes on the first thing
you want to say is
you don't mind you might have to say
what's popping but that's the cadence
you pick what you say i read a comment
from someone that literally said
like nobody can sound bad on this beat
like that's how good this beat is
beats crazy i mean the first time i
heard it the first time i heard it i was
like put that in pro tools right now
before the drums came on as soon as
those piano keys hit
i was like that's mine and i'm just
blessed that i
i'm the one that heard it because the
producer i was poo and jets and they
might have played it for someone else
i think anyone would have snagged that
beat because that's first listen
material that's what's so special about
that song is the first time you hear it
you're like i like this
it's the you don't have to grow on you
it's wild how like
fates can change depending on what you
hear on purpose or even by accident
right when it comes to production as
well now
do you think that you're you'll be doing
anything official with justin in the
future is anything in the works
i'd like to um we haven't built a crazy
relationship but we
exchanged numbers and um we follow each
other on ig so
we're cool we'll see what happens what's
the statement that you're making with
that's what they all say
with the title itself and the and the
focus of the album and the journey for
the listener
huh i think for me the biggest focus of
the album was
to not be pigeonholed by what was
popping was which was a great song but
you know people put me in these boxes
they have this and that to say about me
and the title is kind of like ah that's
what they all say i've heard it all
before and
there's so much range and variety on the
album i just wanted to show that i'm a
true
true musician a true songwriter i'm
gonna be making stuff that
is different from just the raps what is
it like
when you are um you know you're getting
attention for all this stuff
and then you get these big collabs right
on an album you got like
adam levine you get big sean and there's
always that balance of like
we know that these people are excellent
to work with and they'll
bring listeners in but i've also got to
stand on my own two feet
right like where do you find that
balance
well any song i bring to somebody
typically
i'm very secure in what i've done
already and i feel like
all they're adding is compliments to it
it's really more of a challenge
when people bring you a record that they
kill and you have to figure out how to
stand next to them
and those are challenges i enjoy but
when you're the one bringing people
record i knew all them songs that i was
saying hey can
hop on this hop on this i didn't think
anybody was going to kill me on them
because i was very secure
so you kind of have the upper hand when
you go first a little bit but then
there's something to be said for
if you go second you might just upstage
somebody so
it's a risky take but i'm really happy
with how everything came out and i'm
thankful to everybody that hopped on
how do you choose who you want to uh
collaborate with and how do you
actually like do you reach out to them
yourself yeah a lot of times and
sometimes like for example the big sean
record
uh i was sitting on that for months and
trying to figure out oh am i gonna have
to finish it i had a second verse on
there the song was done
but i didn't love my second verse it
felt a little monotonous
and so big sean dm me just told me that
he loved tyler hero
and i was like word good looking let's
let's link and we met in la and i played
him the song and he
he did the verse in front of me so
there's that and then
adam levine's team reached out to me a
lot of these features came from people
reaching out to me and me having a song
ready like oh
i'm glad you like my stuff let's do this
they say preparation meets opportunity
is that exactly what happened there yeah
i'd say
i'd say so it's good to have some stuff
ready i have a lot of artists that
i've literally envisioned we talk about
the manifesting i'm waiting for them to
dm me because i have the song that i'm
gonna send to them ready
yeah right on like is that something you
could say to us about who you have ideas
about
yeah i mean andre 3000 that's one of my
bucket list artists that i hope one day
i get to rap with
he raps when he wants drake of course
it's a huge one
um i've been listening to don toliver i
like brent
fires a lot a lot of those guys yeah
now you had said in the past um you know
your parents were
a little bit nervous back in the day
about maybe this
career choice how are they how they
feeling now what's it like
with your among your closest oldest
friends and your family
it's a lot of pride it's a lot of um a
lot of joy that's one of my favorite
parts is
making the people that watch me grow
proud um
so it's really special to be able to do
this in front of them and share the
experiences with them that that's really
what i like is
oh come on this trip with me oh come
experience this where with me i'm
throwing a party come to the party you
know what i'm saying
we get experience things together so um
i just want to spoil my parents it's i
just want
i just want my parents to experience
things they would have never experienced
had i not done this that's what makes me
excited oh i want to take you to europe
i want to do this and that i want to
i want to do all this stuff with them
it's fine like it's never a case of
your parents cramping yourself like mom
i'm talking to big sean right now
can you not touch me right now maybe
when i was younger when i was back when
i was a spry
team i might have been like mom but now
you know i'm older and
i love having my mom around everybody
likes my mom too i got cool parents
nice she gonna feature on the next one
she was on this one
she was uh she had a little um what
would you call it
like an interlude she was at the end to
keep it light with some advice she
wasn't rapping but she
she has some bars nice now let's talk
about fashion for a minute i know you
said you're not
exactly a sneaker head but you got this
deal with new balance are they sending
you
a ton of shoes all the time like how big
is the collection now yeah anything that
drops is
coming through the crib so the
collection is getting a little
a little excessive i i have a few people
that are in my circle to wear the same
shoe size of me and we share sometimes
because it's just
it's fun that way so
you know bringing us all back around to
manifestation you've gotten to this
point
and you dreamed about it ten years from
now what are you manifesting
[Music]
i think in ten years i'm gonna be seen
as
one of the greats in the genre to ever
do it i'm gonna be a mogul
i have extended my business to other
places and ideally i'll be
helping other artists get on and going
back to my city and
building a real infrastructure and um a
way for other kids to
pop off i have dreams of louisville
being a hub
you know it's bigger than just me when
you represent a city that's why i
represent my city so much is
it gives me a purpose aside from just
indulging from myself
um and i really want to see louisville
become that because we have a strong
culture and it hasn't been put on the
map the way it should but it's starting
to be with guys like me
bryson estg is it's moving
so i'm excited about the future
you